Elon Musk has declared war on Disney not
only is Gina Carano suing over her
termination for her free speech from the
show Mandalorian but Elon Musk has gone
further and said that anyone who's been
fired to hit him up and he will provide
legal support I don't know if this means
they're going class action but it looks
like something akin to what we were
seeing with the Mark Cuban Fiasco Mark
Cuban of course is defending the farle
the Dei in the workplace which is
explicitly overtly illegal Elon Musk has
decided to jump into the culture War fry
and he is going after these big
corporations starting with Disney so
we'll talk a lot about that that's big
Donald Trump has called for a budlight
boycott ceasefire yep nobody cares
they're all tweeting back at his uh at
the post that's being shared from truth
social saying nope doesn't matter what
Trump says if budl does not apologize no
one is going to buy their beer